dude take my time writing my name on the
food if he's gonna eat it to waste of
time she's having a ketchup sandwich
yeah as roommates you know you want to
share stuff you know be there for each
other but when it comes to food mmm-hmm
mmm-hmm that has to be territorial and
bears should respect that fact bears
prefer fresh fish over any other kind of
food sort of uh found that out the hard
way didn't we what I like to do put some
fresh fish on his side of the fridge
that way he leaves my food alone which i
think is a perfect scenario except that
smell that smell is bad why do they
smell like that fish are constantly
taking a bath fact bears don't have
opposable thumbs know what that means
means they can't open jars like I can
you want breakfast cereal put it in jars
you can even put a whole chicken in a
jar they make jars that are big enough
for that you're not going to eat a whole
pizza by yourself and you don't share it
with a bear either get the pizza in the
jar sour gummy worms you're thinking why
would have buried that colors of course
they're gonna eat it oh I started this
banana and now I can't finish up but
I'll bet I can finish it around noon
time when I need another burst of
potassium jelly get your jelly into a
jar wait this is a jar is already in a
jar yeah but some food items you buy
already bear proof